>> THERE IS GROWING CONCERN
TONIGHT ABOUT A NEW WAVE OF
ATTACKS BY RUSSIAN HACKERS
TARGETING U.S. INSTITUTIONS.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD IS WORKING THE
STORY FOR US.
BRIAN, EVERYBODY SEEMS TO
BELIEVE THESE ATTACKS COULDN'T
BE HAPPENING WITHOUT VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S A BLESSING.
>> VERY LIKELY THAT ARE
HAPPENING WITH THIS BLESSING,
WOLF.
A U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS
IDENTIFIED THE HACKERS AS BEING
PART OF RUSSIA'S FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE.
TONIGHT, WE HAVE NEW
INFORMATION ON THE BREACH AND
THE TARGETS.
>> TONIGHT, NO REPORTS THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S ARMY OF
HACKERS IS AGAIN TARGETING
AMERICA.
MICROSOFT, ANNOUNCING THAT THE
SAME HACKERS BEHIND THE MASSIVE
SOLARWINDS ATTACK LAST YEAR,
ARE AT IT AGAIN.
MICROSOFT SAYS THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT HAS IDENTIFIED THE
PERPETRATORS AS BEING FROM
RUSSIA'S TOP FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE, THE AS WE
ARE.
THIS TIME MICROSOFT SAYS, THEY
BREACHED AS MANY AS 14 I.T.
PROVIDERS, SEEKING ACCESS TO
THEIR CLOUD CUSTOMERS,
GOVERNMENTS, THINK TANKS AND
OTHER COMPANIES.
>> MAYBE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY CAN OPERATIONALIZE AND USE
FOR EXPLOITATION.
MAYBE IT'S INFORMATION THAT CAN
GIVE THEM A COMPETITIVE EDGE
AND ECONOMIC INFORMATION OR
RECENT DEVELOPMENTS.
>> IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW
SUCCESSFUL THIS LATEST ATTACK
HAS BEEN, BUT DAVID SANGER OF
THE NEW YORK TIMES, WHICH FIRST
REPORTED THIS STORY, SAYS IT
PRESENTS A NEW LEVEL OF THREAT
FOR RUSSIAN HACKERS.
>> WITH THE RUSSIANS HAVE
CONSISTENTLY TRY TO DO WITH THE
SOLARWINDS ATTACK, BACK IN THE
END OF LAST YEAR AND WITH THIS
ONE, IS TO GET INTO THE SUPPLY
CHAIN, THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS ALL THE SYSTEMS.
RATHER THAN TRY TO BREAK INTO
YOUR ACCOUNT, OR MY ACCOUNT OR
ANYBODY ELSE'S, RATHER THAN GET
INTO SOME SYSTEM THAT THEY
WOULD RATHER DO IT IN MASS.
>> EARLIER THIS YEAR, THE WHITE
HOUSE CLAIM THAT THE SAME
RUSSIAN SPY AGENCY PUT THE
SOLARWINDS ATTACK, WHICH
BREACHED THOUSANDS OF USERS AND
SOUGHT TO ALTER SOFTWARE USED
BY THE U.S. GOVERNMENT IN
COMPANIES.
AT A SUMMIT IN JUNE, BIDEN
WARNED PUTIN TO STOP.
>> WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT CYBER
CAPABILITY.
AND HE KNOWS IT.
HE DOESN'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IT
IS, BUT IT'S SIGNIFICANT.
AND IN FACT, IF THEY VIOLATE
THESE BASIC NORMS, WE WILL
RESPOND.
>> HE KNOWS.
>> SINCE THEN, DESPITE MORE
U.S. SANCTIONS AND EXPULSIONS
THIS YEAR, AND ANOTHER BIDEN
WARMING TO PUTIN BY PHONE IN
JULY, NOT ONLY HAS THERE BEEN
THIS LATEST HACK, BUT ALSO MORE
ELECTIONS INFORMATION EFFORTS.
>> LOOK AT WHAT RUSSIA IS DOING
ALREADY ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION
IN MISINFORMATION.
IT'S A PURE VIOLATION OF OUR
SOVEREIGNTY.
>> PUTIN KEEPS CROSSING BIDEN'S
RED LINES ON CYBERATTACKS, AND
IS FLEXING HIS MUSCLE AHEAD OF
THIS WEEK'S G20 SUMMIT IN ROME,
EVEN THOUGH HE WON'T BE THERE
IN PERSON.
>> PUTIN IS AN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER.
HE WAS IN THE AGENCY THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEING ACCUSED OF
HAVING ATTACKING OUR NETWORKS.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE EVER GONNA
PERSUADE PUTIN TO STOP ENGAGING
IN INTELLIGENCE GATHERING.
HE'S BEEN DOING IT SINCE HE WAS
A TEENAGER.
>> THE KREMLIN HAS CONSISTENTLY
DENIED ANY INVOLVEMENT IN THESE
CYBERATTACKS, AS FOR ANY
POSSIBLE U.S. RESPONSE THIS
TIME, U.S. OFFICIALS HAVE NOT
PUBLICLY DISCUSSED RETALIATION,
AND ANALYSTS SAY THE